8h30 hier matin tous les musiciens de
l'orchestré de léonie sont là pour la
plupart d'entre eux c'est inédit
ils vont jouer en prison pour la
première fois ce féraud après les
formalités administratives
direction le gymnase du centre de
détention c'est là que va se dérouler la
répétition de deux heures de musique
ample années sous la houlette de son
chef
vous êtes à fond
à quelques mètres d'eux lors qu'être ils
sont là attentif et intéressé
une quarantaine de détenus des hommes et
des femmes souvent très éloignés de la
musique classique est encore plus de
l'eau perd déjà ça nous a donné envie
d'écouter de la musique classique ce qui
n'est pas toujours évident ça nous a
permis de la comprendre
on se projette sur un autre univers on
est toujours enfermé ici c'est béton
barbelés
là c'est une grande bouffée d'oxygène
c'est un grand bien-être
peut-être quelque chose qui fera du jeu
à un moment donné se souviendront que
oui on les a pas mis n'a pas écarté
complètement de la société et que leur
apporter aussi quelque chose qui fait
plaisir et qui lors de leur vie aussi
pour quelque chose libération une
répétition de carmen mené tambour
battant dans un esprit chaleureux et
participatif
certains ont même eu le privilège de
prendre la place du chef quelques
instants à bob sonepar valeureux faux
départ phone est parfois bien mieux
c'est parce qu'en fait c'était le
mauvais sens
et en fait il faut juste faire 2 sing
stasi en fait 2-1 en plus il sera plus
c'est juste ou aujourd'hui un son avec
son très binaire
c'est oui non ça va vers autre chose
bravo et son salut il vous avez vu bravo
et bravo merci beaucoup